c'est une histoire méconnue du passé
montréal il ya 45 ans cette semaine les
étudiants de l'université sur john
williams maintenant l'université
concordia mener c'est une des frondes
les plus violentes
maintenant défendre les plus violentes
de l'histoire du pays au nom d'égalité
entre les blancs et les noirs comme nous
le dit jean-sébastien cloutier le
pavillon et louis-paul de l'université
concordia
c'est ici il y à 45 ans qu'une
intervention policière entraîna une des
plus violentes manifestations étudiantes
de l'histoire canadienne
une centaine d'arrestations et 2
millions de dollars de dommages à
l'origine des événements
ce professeur de biologie perry anderson
6 de ses étudiants noirs lui reprochent
de les faire échouer par racisme
un comité est alors créé par
l'université pour enquêter mais aucun
étudiant dont fait partie la plainte
pour racisme est rejetée l'analyse de
ces notes n'a pas conclu il ya là une le
préjugé contre cet étudiant la décision
du comité en train d'abord une
occupation pacifique du neuvième étage
du pavillon rôle pendant dix jours
mais les négociations traînent et quand
la police intervient tout dégénère dans
l'université les étudiants installe des
barricades
ils saccagent du matériel informatique
des feux sont allumés et les pompiers
doivent intervenir par les fenêtres
les étudiants rejettent des appareils
des dossiers sont détruits et il pleut
des feuilles sur la rue mai khai il va
81 17 étudiants affectés la plupart
étaient blancs cette solidarité parmi
les étudiants après l'émeute berendsen
réintègre son poste
l'université elle décidera d'intégrer
les étudiants dans ces comités et de
créer un bureau de l'ombudsman
le leader du mouvement roosvelt d'agglos
purge à deux ans de prison avant de
devenir plus tard premier ministre de
son pays natal la dominique
une autre contestataire en course est
par la suite devenue la première noire
nommée au sénat canadien
cette époque où on les a remarqués était
une revendication celle des noirs aux
états unis d étudier en france et des
nationalistes au québec il y avait un
esprit de libération à d'honneur à
l'époque le long métrage de l'office
national du film racontera bientôt cette
page de l'histoire montréalaise ici
jean-sébastien cloutier radio canada
montréal